I realized that I've been making a lot
of videos where I talk about different
theological schools or ideas within
Islam or the Islamic religion but as the
viewer Noah hacia pointed out I've never
actually made a video where I explain
these schools or these ideas thoroughly
so here's that video Islamic theology
and Kalam is a very broad subject that
would really take a whole series to go
through properly so this video will only
focus on the early development and the
very early schools and movements within
the Islamic theological tradition and as
you will soon find out as with most
other subjects that we discuss there is
a lot of diversity at play here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so basically all Islamic theology stems
from or has as its basis the concept
known as tawheed which is what is
expressed in the islamic proclamation of
faith la ilaha illa-llah there's no god
but God so tawheed means that there is
only one God but also that God is one
but he cannot be divided into parts that
he is not one out of selection of
multiple that he is oneness he is one
this is the only thing really at all
that I can comfortably say that
basically all Muslims in history have
agreed on so if we wind the clock to the
seventh century the Prophet Mohammed has
just died after reciting the Quran for
the last 22 years of his life this
sudden death of this prophet left his
community in a state of shock and
confusion not knowing how to interpret
this Quranic event this prophetic event
and how to understand this new scripture
or recitation the Quran without the
guiding hand of a prophet who can
interpret for them and so because of
this a lot of different schools and
ideas and movements emerged in the very
early Muslim community I've discussed in
other video some of the main general
movements that emerged in this early
Islamic community one of them being of
course fit or jurisprudence which is
what we could call Islamic law as the
process of trying to figure out what
this thing called the Sharia is
basically figuring about how one should
live as a Muslim how one should conduct
affairs how one should perform religious
rites and ceremonies and so on doesn't
be the very practical aspects of the
religion there was also what's known as
fanciful or philosophy which was
basically philosophy derived from the
Greek tradition included translations of
all Greek classics I'm Plato and
Aristotle of Latinas and who would then
also try to synthesize this or or
interpret the Islamic revelation or the
Islamic teachings in light of these old
Greek teachings
there was also Sufism or tasawwuf which
is the mystical and often ascetical
practices and theoretical tendencies
that also emerged in this period and
then lastly there is column which is
what we'll talk about in this video
today a kalam the word column literally
means speech these categories like
column Sufism and fanciful not be seen
as mutually exclusive the lines between
them are often very blurry also column
does not necessarily mean theology in a
general sense when we say column we mean
a more specific movement who used you
could say rational debate or
argumentation to to convey or to try to
understand or interpret certain beliefs
and teachings within the Quran and later
also the hadith literature and so
because of this the lines between
falsify and column can be very blurry
the especially early on at this early
phase the biggest difference being that
the philosophers the Philosopher's were
more putting more emphasis on the Greek
tradition and trying to interpret those
texts the Quran has some basic
theological teachings like the idea of
tawheed which I mentioned but it doesn't
answer all questions clearly and so
early on the word debates about a number
of questions relating to it some of the
most prominent theological questions in
this early phase include questions of
the attributes of God the nature of
Quran and the revelation freewill versus
determinism and the nature of faith and
sin and much more now we need to get
some basic problems out of the way the
common idea that there was an orthodoxy
from the beginning that was challenged
by diverging sects must be discarded if
we want this discussion to remain
academically and historically accurate
much like in early Christianity there is
no orthodoxy but a chaotic explosion of
different ideas movements and schools of
thoughts a kind of Orthodox position in
this way doesn't emerge until around the
turn of the millennium and even then
orthodoxy is always a fluid term that is
never fixed or monolithic but in this
vast array of different interpretations
and understand
of theological ideas or theological
concepts there are a few questions and
movements that are worth talking about
and one of the early most hotly debated
questions was the question of free will
and it seems that many of the earthy
omayyad caliphs and any many people in
the Muslim community in general seems to
have held a deterministic position that
we don't have free will but that God is
in control of every event in every
action even our own actions and this of
course upholds God's absolute power but
it also comes with another problem
because the Quran and the Islamic
religion generally speaks about certain
responsibilities that we are to act in a
certain way that we have certain rituals
that we need to perform in order to
avoid going to hell for example but if
we don't have free will then what's the
point of you are following these
prescriptions if we're actually not in
control then why is the Quran telling us
to do anything this led some Muslim
scholars many associated with the PIAT
istic school called the kaduri's to
argue that we indeed we do have free
will and that we are responsible for our
own actions a similar opinion was held
by the ecology of an extreme group who
seceded from Ali's army and opposed the
Umayyad regime they also held the belief
in free will as would the more moderate
offshoot of the bodies later on the
college i'ts insistence on free will is
related to their strict ideas about sin
and belief which was another theological
question that was discussed at this time
according to the college Heights and
later the embodies a person's beliefs
and actions are intimately connected so
if a person commits a grave sins that
sort of revokes his status as a believer
or a muslim and this is for example why
some college i'ts felt like they could
assassinate ali because they felt that
his actions had made him lose his status
as a Muslim other groups disagreed in
groups like the mogea argued that the
judgment on sinners especially those of
the past should be left to God and thus
promoted unity in the community by
trying to end this constant arguing over
sinning to them faith and action are
separated
faith is something that is completely
internal and can only be expressed
verbally whereas actions can only
indicate one's beliefs but don't have a
direct correspondence in the words of
collet Blankenship quote thus bowing to
the Sun or to an idol could only be an
indication of unbelief and not unbelief
in itself only God can know the true
state of a person's faith or beliefs and
thus he is the only one who can also
judge them thus according to this belief
sinners cannot be called unbelievers but
at worst misguided believers the mogea
are considered to be extinct today but
some of the basic ideas of this moment
has survived into the Hanafi school of
law and the materially school of Calem
other questions which were discussed
include the question of Hell or the
nature of hell
some believe that hell was temporary and
that everyone would be allowed into
paradise eventually while others saw
hell as eternal we also have debates
regarding God and his attributes as well
as the nature of the Quran and
revelation which I'll return to soon but
what's important to remember is that in
this very early stage we're talking the
first century basically we can't we talk
about schools of thought and in the
strict sense but rather sort of loosely
associated movements that held similar
beliefs but also people within these so
called movements often could hold
competing views on certain questions
while agreeing on others so we we're not
talking about a set of fixed schools at
this point what's usually considered the
first proper school of doctrinal
theology or column is what is known as
the mortise illa its origins is often
attributed to the thinker wasps 11 Atta
and wood real a significant level of
prominence in the following centuries
the Mata Silla is characterized by a
strong use of Reason in determining
their theological and doctrinal
interpretations and understandings this
wasn't all that uncommon at the time
similar tendencies will be popular in
jurisprudence or 5th at the time as well
but this emphasis on logic and
rationality did lead to some of the
characteristic teachings of this
particular school firstly the Motta's
illa were strong supporters of free will
God creates human
with the ability to choose and to act
they also held that in order to retain
God's oneness and transcendence and thus
the doctrine of tawheed he must be
without any creaturely qualities there
was some at this time who taught that
God had a physical body or some kind of
body at least since many Quranic verses
talked about his hands and face and him
sitting on the throne and so on the
Motta's Allah and many others instead
argue that all such verses of the Quran
should be read allegorically or
metaphorically and not literally God is
thus absolutely beyond comprehension and
has no qualities or attributes as such
regarding the debate on qualities like
power and life or knowledge they argued
that these aren't attributes that God
has as a part of himself but that these
attributes are his essence quote God
knows through himself rather than a
knowledge other than himself so he God
doesn't have knowledge God is knowledge
and he knows through himself which is
the knowledge that he is and so on it
and perhaps most famously and a point
that would constitute what is perhaps
the most heated debate at the time they
held that the Quran was created rather
than being Co eternal with God and we
will return to this debate shortly in a
general sense the Mata Salah prayer a
strong emphasis on Apple or intellect as
well as reason to determine or
understand the world but also God and
revelation and all of these ideas were
present in the region and the Muslim
community before this but the Mantis ala
can be said to be the first proper
school or sort of a unified movement who
very much proclaimed these ideas this
general attitude was part of a larger
trend within the early Muslim community
and one that was at this time actually
predominant even scholars in in
jurisprudence and jurists also favored
rational inquiry and personal opinion
called the right which they used
alongside the Quran and it was only in
later periods that are more strict sore
textual based practice came to be the
norm my implementing hadith and these
things
the earliest Hanafi school of
jurisprudence for example had strong
contact with the Motta's Allah and with
emoji IDEs for
sample but as the 8th century reached
its concluding decades and as the ninth
century started there was another
movement that was very much growing in
prominence and this is a group that is
often called the traditionalists the
traditionalists are often synonymous
with the so-called tradition astoria
al-hadith and they are called this
because these are the people who would
argue for and collect hadith literature
and argue for its wider usage in in both
jurisprudence and fit and also in
theological questions instead of
emphasizing rationality and personal
interpretation they saw this as
problematic as it led to disunity in
both doctrine and practice instead they
favored a strict scriptural approach
where the Quran was to be read literally
and followed to the letter it is also
this group that around this time became
central to the gathering and collecting
of hadith which is stories and saying of
the Prophet Muhammad and arguing that
these should be used alongside the Quran
almost exclusively in determining
practice and belief at the expense of
rational speculation or personal opinion
so whereas the Motta's Allah believed in
free will the traditionalist were
deterministic they didn't want to divest
God of any power over creation including
human actions similarly they wanted to
read the Quran literally and so God to
them had anthropomorphic qualities as
they are described in the Quran they
criticized the MOT hazardous belief in
God's nature as denying his attributes
so remember the Motta's Allah said that
God doesn't have attributes as described
in the Quran that these are to be read
metaphorically and even the essential
attributes like life and knowledge are
only they're not part of his essence
they are his essence and so the
traditionalist would very much criticize
this and say that they are denying God
his attributes as you might expect they
also denied the idea that the Quran was
created but instead that it was
uncreated and Co eternal with God being
God's speech they argued that there
could not have been a time when God did
not speak or know the Quran and so it
must have existed before creation and
it's kind of similar to debates in early
in theology where people discussed the
nature of Christ is he equal to God or
subordinate to him like the Aryans held
this question of the creativeness of the
Quran may seem like a trivial question
but it does actually have some
significant implications some would
argue that if we say that the Quran is
created at a specific point in time then
this seems to mean that it was also
catered to a specific audience and this
could also then lead to a larger
openness in reinterpreting to new times
in your situations whereas an eternal
Quran makes this a bit more difficult
the traditionalists are also
characterized like I said by our
veterans for collecting and use of
hadith literature which they thought
should be used to compliment the Quran
in a very comprehensive way the Motta's
Allah on the other hand were sometimes
skeptical or outright hostile to the
hadith literature sometimes even calling
it sir mere guesswork and even calling
them absurd and blasphemous they argue
that the hadith were simply used and
fabricated by the traditionalists to
support the ideological positions and
thus constituted Buddha or innovation
and this is a position that they shared
with many of the early jurists as well
while this division is rather
generalizing and there was most likely
more of a spectrum of positions and
people in between these two extremes but
the Motta's Allah and the
traditionalists would engage in debates
and polemical arguments for a long time
in this early period the question of the
creativeness of the Quran became an
especially heated debate in the early
9th century the term created in this
sense does not mean that they believed
that the Quran was created or written by
a human being not even Muhammad there
was no debate about whether or not the
Quran was God's Word in a literal sense
everyone in this debate agreed on this
the question was whether God created it
at a specific point in time like he
creates other objects in the world or if
it being God's speech existed eternally
with him now opinions on the nature of a
relation varied in this early period
there seems to have been even those who
viewed Muhammad as having composed the
Quran to some degree or at least that he
had a much
bigger role to play in its composition
but no writings or references to these
groups and in a secure sense survives to
this day however the is smiley Shia it's
held a similar positions and thought
that the Quran was caught the divinely
inspired word of the Prophet Muhammad in
any case at the time of the Motta's
Allah and tradition is debate and in the
Sunni world generally the majority of
Muslims had adopted the idea of the
Quran as God's literal word and thus
this is the context in which this
particular debate takes place the
rationale Motta's in the position was
often supported by the Abbasid caliphs
and was popular among the educated elite
of society by the time of caliph al
Mamoon
it was even adopted as a state doctrine
the question of the creativeness of the
quran was especially important for a lot
more than his supporters at this time
and since the traditionalists were
growing in popularity this led to an
infamous episode that is often referred
to as the Mahina or the inquisition as
mowett as ilysm was adopted as state
policy the traditionalist position was
seen as a threat to what they considered
to be right doctrine as a result the
state officials would sometimes force
traditionalist scholars to accept the
idea that the Quran was created some of
these scholars reluctantly accepted and
did affirm this position while others
refused and were often not treated too
well as a result the proper Mahina
started in 833 in which some of these
scholars who had refused to affirm the
metalic position were arrested and
imprisoned and these scholars included
the very famous scholar and hadith
collector Hamad bin hanbal who is the
namesake of the Han Valley law school he
has become significant later on as the
kind of arch traditionalist who is the
face of this whole movement as I said
he's also the founder and namesake of
the Han buddy law school which is often
considered to be the most strict and
conservative of all of the mainstream
schools and when we talk about
traditionalist theology it is sometimes
known as Hanbali theology Ahmed even
Hannibal was arrested and even tortured
in their attempt
accept the position that the Quran was
created but he continuously refused
state support for my desert ISM in
particular officially ended in 851 and
as you can imagine the Inquisition and
the general way that the state forced
acceptance of Matt Hazzard isn't in that
way really only had the opposite effect
it really completely backfired on them
and even humble and others who had been
imprisoned or tortured became like
martyrs for this movement which only
increased its popularity in the wider
Muslim world they were seen as heroes
who stood up for their beliefs while DK
lives and by extension the Mata Silla
were suddenly associated with oppression
and persecution
thus sometime in the 9th century the
traditionalist position started to gain
the upper hand in the asserting world
both in terms of theology and
jurisprudence the use of hadith as a
primary source of law and practice which
had been so criticized by somewhat Azula
and earlier jurists was given a
prominent role as second only to the
Quran and even as an essential part of
revelation by traditionally oriented
thinkers like Imam and Shafi and I have
been humble which then became the norm
for all Islamic law in theological
matters similar tendencies took place
the triumph of each traditionalist can
be attributed to as we have seen social
and political factors but also likely
the fact that the more literal
interpretations appealed to a more
general mass of people who viewed God as
a personal being rather than some more
abstract concept however the positions
of people like Ahmed even Hamburg
work often considered extreme even by
more conservative scholars so a pure
traditionalism more humble ism didn't
survive for too long as a widely
accepted doctrine a kind of compromise
or synthesis was needed here in a way
this compromise came with a scholar and
theologian by the name of Al Hassan and
a shaadi he was originally a morte as
light but at some point in his life made
a complete turnaround and became a
humble light from that point on he would
attempt to apply the argumentative
approach of the Motta's ala and apply it
to the Hanbali position and through
doing so created a new school which is
called Arshad ISM or the a Sharia and
from this point on Ashkenazim would
become the most popular and widely
accepted theological school of kalam
throughout the Sunni world it is often
seen as a synthesis or compromise in
between them what hazard on the one hand
and the traditionalists on the other
which is true in one sense but in actual
reality it is a lot closer to the
traditionalists side than to the Motta's
Allah even if it does move away from
some of the extremes of the earlier
traditionalist movement for example the
ash trees tend to argue that the
attributes and qualities of God are real
and Co eternal with him and that they
are neither God himself nor other than
him they often hold that if the Quran
says that God has a certain attribute we
should accept this fact but also accept
the fact that we don't know what this
actually means in reality in a similarly
compromising fashion they hold a middle
position regarding the creativeness of
the Quran the Quran in its essence is
uncreated and eternal but when it is
formulated in letters and sounds
it becomes created humans also have a
certain degree of free will but all
options are created by God so it is a
limited kind of freewill being a Kalam
school they also accepted the practice
of Kalam whereas the traditional
traditionalists were often hostile to
this practice altogether very famous
thinkers like a Bahaman de lavaz Ollie
and Fokker is another Aussie were ash
writes and it would generally hold a
prominent positions among Sunnis
especially those from the Shafi and
Maliki law schools the Hanafi law school
however has often favored another even
later school of Kalam known as tamati
reedy school named after a Burman su
alma to reading this school can be seen
as another kind of compromise or middle
position they are closer to the motifs
Allah than the ash trees are and have
taken some influence from the previously
mentioned mogea movement particularly
the idea that faith and actions are
unconnected and thus only God can truly
know and judge the faith of a believer
in the material school faith doesn't
decrease or increase based on actions
and in this they differed from the ash
trees they also held that fascinating
position where the human being can
rationally determine what is right or
wrong in terms of ethics and in that
sense does not
necessarily need revelation to tell them
what is right and wrong which of course
shows you that they were very strongly
rationalistic they oriented as I've said
the Hanafi school of law often adopted
the maternity school to a large degree
and the school became very prominent
during the Ottoman Empire especially
when the Hanafi school was kind of
official state policy so this is the
basics of the Sunni world the Shia
however are quite different in a
generalizing sense the 12er and Aisha
have actually adopted the Mort as Allah
as its main school of kalam historically
in various forms on the other hand the
Ismaili Shia have their own unique
perspective which is heavily influenced
by the Greek Neoplatonic school in a
very direct sense again in the words of
cladded blankenship around the turn of
the millennium quote the Muslim world
had begun to settle on several defining
and immensely enduring doctrinal
alignments that have not been
substantially altered since the a shaadi
Matuidi and humbly Sunnis two varieties
of metabolism among Twelver and thus
Aisha the neoplatonism of many Smyly
Shia and the Abadi doctrines among the
residual Hutterites I find this a bit
generalizing but it is a good starting
point to understand the different
schools or positions within different
branches of Islam important to remember
is also that the difference between
column and falsa philosophy is often
very blurry and the two were often very
inspired by each other I haven't talked
about any of the Muslim philosophers in
this video but their writings and ideas
very much inspired the Kalam scholars
their ideas and language had a lasting
impact on Kalam theology generally some
theologians violently opposed philosophy
or philosopher while others were more
accepting and adopting it it is
sometimes stated that by the time of ala
Cazale and when he wrote books like the
incoherence of the Philosopher's this
represents a triumph of Kalam and
theology over philosophy but this isn't
really that accurate
not only did falsify survived in a
direct way in the Persian world
especially but the files of a tradition
and its ideas had been used and
incorporated into Kalam argumentation
and thus also survived indirectly in
that way too
and even though I painted a picture
which indicates that by the term of the
first millennium there existed clear
schools of theology that were followed
by certain groups we must remember that
these are all huge generalizations
neither the Mata Salah the ash trees or
the mathura these are fixed institutions
but theological debates have continued
even to this day regarding various
subjects of theology it is an ever
evolving tradition we have also seen a
kind of resurgence of the MOA tasoula in
the sunni world in the last century or
two with the appearance of what is often
referred to as Islamic modernism and
their adoption of my tanzanite ideas
which is often called Neo white as ilysm
basically a lot more happens from the
Middle Ages forward but in this video I
focused on giving you an introduction to
the very early centuries of this
development to give you a basic
understanding of the origins I hope this
video has been educational and
interesting and I would love to keep
this discussion going in the comments if
you want to support this channel you can
of course like the video and subscribe
you can also support me monetarily on
patreon so I'll leave a link to that in
the description if you're interested I
also like to thank everyone who has
chosen to become patrons thus far and
your supporters of course immensely
appreciated and inspires me to keep
working I'll see you next time
[Music]